you're gonna bring people together
that's the goal we are such huge fans of
yours Billy Eilish we love your music
and we think you are such an inspiration
I think the thing that I do the most is
change you've shown us how cool it is to
be ourselves you don't fit into a mold
and that is awesome we've also heard
your concerts are worth every penny
your shows aren't like any other
musicians performance fans never quite
know what to expect from you but we can
always expect that you'll be yourself
every musician has some rules and
guidelines they have to follow on tour
in Billy Isle Isha's case she makes most
of her own rules keep watching to find
out the ten strict rules Billy has to
follow on tour you wouldn't even believe
it
say anything fans for Billy Eilish know
that her music isn't always PG and you
can guarantee that her concerts aren't
family-friendly either because I would
rather not do a show than do a crappy
version honestly Billy definitely
doesn't let anyone tell her what she can
and cannot say on stage she has a strict
say anything policy for her concerts she
doesn't care that she's just a teenager
if people are uncomfortable with her
swearing she thinks they probably won't
enjoy her concerts safety first
this rule is one that Billy loves
breaking like all celebrities she has a
team of bodyguards he'll do anything to
keep her safe most security teams don't
want their celebs interacting closely
with the crowds it can be dangerous and
sometimes fans go crazy but Billy loves
her fans she doesn't shy away from
joining them in the pit she thinks
physicality is as important as safety
baggy clothes Billy has a super unique
style she is a lot more comfortable in
baggy pants and oversized shirts
she likes her baggy clothes because they
match her carefree attitude she also
doesn't want people criticizing her body
after all she's just a teenager no one
wants to hear a bunch of body shaming
comments you won't catch Billy wearing
skin tight clothes and that's another
reason why her fans love her she really
has created her own signature style
no wardrobe on a related note Billy
doesn't have a cent concert wardrobe
most female musicians have a set of
performance clothes for their tours
these are clothes they plan to wear and
they only wear them during a concert but
not Billy she doesn't see the point in
having a specific wardrobe for her
concerts her regular everyday clothes
are the same one she wears to perform
honestly that makes a lot of sense all
about the music
Billy Irish might have a say anything
policy but she also has a don't say a
lot policy it's literally like being in
my head sometimes musicians spend a lot
of time talking to the fans during their
concerts after all they don't get a ton
of time to interact with their audiences
but Billy believes concerts are all
about the music she will talk to her
fans but she isn't super chatty
she knows her fans are there for her
music and so is she speak up most
musicians have managers for their music
and for their tours these managers make
a lot of everyday decisions but Billy
doesn't let anyone make hard decisions
for her she knows her managers would
probably prefer her to keep her mouth
shut but that's not who she is
she will speak her mind about decision
two on tour and decisions about her
music take it easy
tours are hard work and Billy needs time
to relax she struggles with muscle
injuries and she also has Tourette's
syndrome this shoulder neck situation is
so painful when she is tired or stressed
her Tourette's tics get harder to
control she knows it's important to
spend plenty of time chilling out to
stay healthy that way she can be her
absolute best when she performs ignore
the haters this is a rule that Billy
follows every day not just when she's on
tour she knows it's important to ignore
the haters she has said that her music
isn't for everyone there will always be
people who don't like her or her music
but that's okay people have different
tastes she has learned to ignore mean
comments she knows that she is awesome
and plenty of people love her big
brother going on tour is hard and it's
good to have a familiar face with you
Billy brings her brother Phineas
O'Connell on tour
he truly understands her he helps her
make good decisions and encourages her
to stand up for herself phineas has also
collaborated with Billy on her music
creative control it's important to Billy
that she has creative control over her
music she isn't afraid to make music in
more than one genre even though that's
frowned upon in the music industry she
doesn't let people send to her music or
lyrics when she writes them and she
makes sure that her concerts match the
brand she's created for herself and one
of the goals I'd make an album that I
could put 14 people into a room that
each had like fully different tastes
like one person like this one person
like this hey you have you subscribed to
the things yet we post videos about your
favorite topics every single day so hit
that subscribe button and turn on those
post notifications so you never miss
another video watching on your mobile
you can turn on notifications via
YouTube settings that's a wrap on ten
strict rules Billy Eilish has to follow
on tour what's your favorite Billy
Eilish song let us know in the comments
thanks for watching give this video a
big thumbs up if you love Billy we'll
see you next time on the things